oh Lord
the world's oldest Christian Community
says it's feeling the pressure like
never before
ramallah's Orthodox Church was packed
for Christmas day Mass even though
Christians make up just one percent of
the population of the occupied West Bank
down from 11 at the end of the Ottoman
era in 1922 and now with the most
far-right Israeli government there's
ever been few here see that Trend
reversing
the plans of these extreme parties and
what they believe in are based on
expelling the other from holy places in
Jerusalem and all of Palestine that is
unrealistic because we Palestinians have
a long history here we are very rooted
in this land Israel's occupation the
Stranglehold it has on the economy and
the security situation are what drives
most Palestinians to leave
church leaders here have warned that
Christians have become the target of
frequent and sustained attacks by Fringe
radical groups in Jerusalem and the holy
land it's a reminder that Palestinian
Christians say they suffer as much under
Israel's occupation as Muslims do and
this conflict is much more about land
than it is about religion
settlers occupied this privately held
Churchland in Jerusalem with police
protection two weeks ago they say
they're carrying out archaeological digs
the church says it's not granted
permission
more than 30 Christian Graves were
desecrated earlier this week Israel's
foreign Ministry says the vandalism was
an immoral act that is an affront to
religion two teenagers have been
arrested
we are exposed to Israeli aggression and
settlers aggression daily
they damaged cars on roads destroyed
places we are used to that it's not new
but it's increasing with the new
Administration
the message of Christmas is that one day
this land will return to the
Palestinians who have the right to it
and that right will never be lost
the whole world the west and the Arab
world can see what is happening here we
hear their words but we do not see their
actions
Palestinian Christians are often called
The Living Stones of Christianity
because they can trace their history to
the birth of the church two thousand
years ago and in a speech to Mark
Orthodox Christmas present Mahmoud Abbas
said our people will continue to stand
firm on our land the land of our
ancestors
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Ramallah in the
occupied West Bank